the Joe Rogan experience I know it's
probably a [ __ ] ton of money they gave
him and that's all well and good
short-sighted but if you wanted to do it
right this is what you say you say
listen dude we got to get you an amateur
fight against a guy who's well he might
not be it depends on what he's trying to
do but if you wanted to get an amateur
fight against someone who is of similar
skill level and similar experience level
so you feel what it's like to be going
after it Jane jeff mayweather on floor
Mayweather's MMA move he might actually
whoop CM Punk's ass first Oh Floyd
foresee a punk if they sell the [ __ ] out
of that fight Showtime Don
good to see you Joe this is amazing we
got one hell of a fight coming up my
heart be still my heart they might do
that you know I can't take it
my heart is flying in my chest if I saw
Lloyd Mayweather across some CM Punk I'd
be like this is not real life yeah dude
that's the fighting word well listen if
you know that Floyd can't fight Conor in
an MMA fight can let's take that
occasion but the odds of Conor losing
are so astronomically small - 100,000
favorite like whatever the [ __ ] Vegas
puts on it that's cute no I'm here it's
10:00 - I don't think they're gonna do
that another like we don't have odds for
this we can't you guys can't make money
it's gonna be like nine hundred to one
it's gonna be something crazy some
buskers Douglas jaggedness
Buster Douglas is only like 40 - it's
crazy this is gonna be insane if they're
smart because Connor is gonna kick his
legs out he's only gonna get a chance to
come close enough he come at everyone
Connors gonna kick his [ __ ] legs out
he doesn't have any chance and then if
Connor decides to shoot in and clinch
he's gonna clinch and he's going to
ragdoll him well he could jump to a half
garden and do what little you name a
submission nine that's a slap in Connors
- 900 who the [ __ ] made those Oh this is
nonsense that's a joke that's my god you
can take oh my god these people are
crippled my life savings on them that's
the easiest money of all time they're
off by a factor of 10 [ __ ] listen if
this fight takes place
Floyd doesn't have a chance what about
Floyd CM punk though but I got a fight
on Boyd's got a real chance yeah Boyd ko
yeah Boyd's got a real chance unless CM
Punk got away
well also CM Punk way bigger okay let's
be honest about that CM Punk is a guy
who was wrestling probably like 190
pounds can't wait to get to 170 to fight
in the UFC
USANA though son yeah well he's not on
anything
he's pretty loose II guettler WWE SCI
kid right but I'm pretty sure he's at
least according to everybody that I've
talked to and everything I've heard
about him he's a real straightedge no
drinking no I'm not saying he looks like
it he look like now he's clean as they
come right but I think he always was I
really do I don't think he's lying yeah
daddy said Floyd Mayweather is the
[ __ ] greatest boxer maybe of all time
based on paper he is I mean the civilian
swish mints through multiple weight
classes
undefeated 50 you know I don't care if
the last fight was Conor McGregor he's
still 15 I know that's [ __ ] insane
insane yeah dude he's he's on another
level of everybody who's on another
level what this fight is like it's like
it's like you and your buddies at a bar
and Floyd walks in and your buddy goes
who has no background ever maybe did
some performance arts in high school and
you look and go
can you beat up Floyd Mayweather and
then you guys find out you can get
punched in the [ __ ] face very fast in
multiple times the question is can Floyd
fight the same way he fights with big
gloves with MMA gloves the reason why I
say this cuz Floyd's broken his hand
multiple times he said some serious
surgeries on his hands now maybe they've
cured it and maybe it's fine but we all
know that for the longest time
Floyd preferred like a puffier glove a
big flood protection and but he hasn't
had hand problems in a while so maybe he
did fix it and his hands looked [ __ ]
great against Conor
how many pay-per-views does CM Punk
Floyd do
and where where do we stop this is where
you got to come and cut this [ __ ] out
because I heard I heard Morgan Freeman
throws a mean sidekick do we see he
could sell pay-per-views do we [ __ ]
sign him up you know I'm saying like we
cite George Clooney
no Larry King someone's dying so what is
dying they may catch a once they start
swinging we might lose them both good
god man it's crazy it's crazy we're even
talking about
its greatest odds of carniverous Floyd
in the mixed martial arts match and you
know what else is crazy is Floyd
actually considering it Floyd's talking
as at Showtime about an MMA fight I
think he's gonna make a half a billion
dollars
wait till I fight anyone this planet if
I fight Francis could be even the same
night for half a billion dollars half a
billion it's really possible I mean they
really might rake it in with that fight
and the UFC is going to change might be
willing to do it if they met imagine if
they made a deal - Duke - he goes
alright say one more MMA I'll do one MMA
and one more box and God just slow you
know there's a yourself lock him up
again and you know there's a market for
it that would be crazy money and the
actual anime heads are turning over in
their graves they [ __ ] hate this I
think you could sell it I think if
Connor decided to give like five six
months for a training camp Conor
McGregor in talks over stunning five
hundred million dollar rematch with
Floyd Mayweather crazy get your money
wait get your money man can't wait hit
your [ __ ] money and honor cannot wait
but I would say CM Punk because this is
what happens that like jion's over Floyd
seeing that CM Punk would have to figure
out how to get to take down if they
could agree to me it like 160 something
like that maybe I tell Duke Rufus take
this one out and I'm army crawl over to
Floyd cuz the keys my face and I just
get over this leg it's a complete [ __ ]
show and I [ __ ] just sweep as knee
that little tiny scrawny ankles out and
I crawl on top mount and they'd stop the
fight
what if Floyd Mayweather knows karate
will - seriously what if we've never
seen it before he's been hiding it
behind closed doors and he comes out
sideways and starts throwing sidekicks
you like no it's you know you imagine if
Floyd starts throwing perfect muy Thai
leg kicks swap what's crazy this is like
you need my buddy in sixth grade talking
about crazy [ __ ] mutants fighting
rocket fire but let me ask you this in
all austenite grown man if you are a
world championship boxer you're gonna be
exposed to a certain amount of kick
boxers wouldn't you say hey man show me
how to do that how do I do that it would
put what part of the leg you hit messing
around like right here oh [ __ ] that
hurts
yeah oh [ __ ] now show me how to do it
show him how to do it on the back okay I
like Floyd Mayweather pick up kicks like
the Aster mine the way that he could
find was a smartest people I've ever
been around
he learns how to dig his body into
things you just transfer that to his way
brilliant he would start snapping front
kicks on people roundhouse kicks next
thing you know you can't get close
enough you know what that sounds like
the move your kickboxer I'd CM Punk
stand up in his locker room they hear
this Floyd just on the thing
yeah and CM Punk's going what the [ __ ]
no one told me this dude man repeats
Pratt Pete's Brad some gangster that's
how about Pete swap he's a monster for a
long he would hurt your [ __ ] legs man
Pete's Pratt's another dude like when
you watch them kick the pads you'd be
like yes certain guys yikes
no one that I've ever seen kick anything
other than a person may be more
terrified than watching Pedro his Oh
kick a heavy bag one day
you
[Applause]